welcome to this episode of not too deep
I am very excited for you to listen and
or watch this episode because we have V
one the only Tony Hale with us he is an
amazing comedian amazing actor amazing
children's book author and also
voiceover actor and just genuinely a
wonderful lovely human being that
struggles on a daily basis with anxiety
like the rest of us and I might have had
an out-of-body experience reporting this
episode with him because he was so kind
and wonderful that I'm still processing
it and I'm very excited for you guys to
see it and I'm gonna stop this run-on
sentence now so you can just jump into
it enjoy this episode of not too deep
with Tony he'll quick question for you
are you craving flavor and refreshment
this summer please respond audibly at
whatever device you are listening to
this podcast on awesome will pick one of
the three flavors of Bud Light cholita
shilada sorry tomato tomahto
original extra lime and the newest
member of the family mango Bud Light
shilada is perfect for drinking at
brunch on the beach or just hanging out
with friends in the Sun pick up a Bud
Light slightest day and learn more at
Bud Light comm but like gelada flavor
that refreshes your sweatshirt
thank you I cried like a baby during
that oh if you didn't hear it's a sign
of being an actual sociopath actually
that was one of the things that reminded
me that like humanity can be good I know
I wanted to get more into his sons
that's one thing I want that's I I got
into a little bit of a tiff with the
person I went to see it with afterwards
cuz I wanted to know more about its
personal like family life yeah and they
were like why can't you just appreciate
how good it was and I was like I do I do
appreciate you but I just want to see
like one crack and like the surface to
when he I mean he was such a wonderful
man but when he would use puppets during
fights with his sons
uh-huh and I was like ah there's
something more to unpack I was super
super curious about yeah and then I had
to check myself of being like why can't
I just be happy for how happy this makes
everyone right made me so happy I
literally cried
halfway through it well that's what we
have Brian Huskey on here a couple
months ago yeah and yeah you know his
whole series I was like this is like I
wanted to see the darker side and Tom
Hanks is doing a movie coming out about
him oh that's very yeah do you feel like
you were slighted I don't know I mean I
understand what they I understand what
they were doing I think it's just
because he was so interesting in his
whole you know going before Congress and
all that part I had no real idea about
yeah that was so interesting we just
kind of wanted to your point just dive
in a little yeah I wanted to get a
little bit deeper I wanted to find out
more about his wife who seemed to be
like kind of a consummate support system
and like pillar for him with like no
qualms about it and I'm like I want to
know more about you like there must have
been some kind of stuff going he didn't
shy away from there was that one thing
in the show where he was I guess the
puppets are asking the kid what do you
think assassination means or something I
was like damn yes so ballsy and so long
ago yeah and I guess maybe we've already
started yeah okay if that's okay yeah me
too this is already very pre-recorded so
anything that you're like I don't want
to talk about that it's very okay and
normal no I get I grew up I guess like I
knew of him and and I but I never like
sat down every day and watched it I
don't know why but for something in me
growing up I was just like there's
something a little bit off to me about a
man that's like taking off his shoes and
talking directly at a camera to me that
said like Barney made more sense to me
and some reason in my point it's like I
do the same thing but he had he had a
lot of critics he had a lot critics when
he was doing it but they're just the
purity you just rose to the surface and
it isn't that kind of telling on us
maybe this is just me talking at you
about me that me too all of us really
that it's like there's got to be
something [ __ ] up about him behind the
scenes and like maybe he was just an
extremely pure man I mean we're all a
work in progress I think he was his own
work in progress but what he chose
rather than cynicism or negativity was
incredibly admirable super pure yeah
super wonderful and you have a daughter
[Laughter]
taking Instagram photos with over the
course of her child because I need to be
more relatable she's 13 she's just a
little show to school this weekend and
we went and it's very she's precious her
name is LOI LOI Loy how did you come up
with that name it is a southern family
name and so my wife's father was named
Loy and then her his son her brother was
named Loy and then Loy is the only girl
who was five different generations and
her my wife's brother Roy passed away
that was also named in honor of him
that's very very cool yeah it's also
just a very cool name and not one of
those like Gucci like new aging names
interesting I was a poor thing every
time she says they say what's your name
she goes Loy like joy with an owl so
she's always says I say that cuz people
think she says joy which I think is that
but that's cute I mean there's a much
worse way of like trying to explain your
name to someone but what's the claiming
of like children's entertainment
nowadays I have no pulse on that at all
it's all about YouTube I feel really
good oh yeah does she watch like the
kids unboxing video things she doesn't
watch that but she'll watch um she
there's there's this fan I started
playing with this
really in the Shane Dawson's conspiracy
very she loves him she she watches what
does she watch she'll like show like
when music Blake Taylor Swift's music
video came out so she likes to watch
those music that she also watch like
certain families about their lives like
family vloggers and that sort of thing
yes yeah like when they just about their
family and she enjoys that she loved
slime videos was a big thing yeah while
oh and also those about cooking it's but
it's like they'll do all those funky
designs on cakes and stuff like that
should watch that kind it's very very
sweet I of course do I'll I'll just I
don't know if you watch YouTube but I
watched like um I don't watch the family
children today's a day I admit that
that's my favorite genre I'm so glad you
came out i watch like compilation videos
of like like on the voice when they win
or like they get chosen and the blind
audition but I never want to see the
rejections because I don't want to see
any the rejection and I'll see like
soldiers coming home to their dogs that
brings me such joy also dog fail
compilations are one of my favorite will
fail compilations in general are pretty
funny I've said a million times in this
podcast but if you look up men falling
off of boats is a really really great
accomplishment it's like just men that
are really proud of their boats and then
the boat takes them over and cut -
tomorrow I'm on a boat and I just
they're not hurt just pride like the
pride is damaged yeah sound satisfying
but that's so she watches YouTube she
watches YouTube and then she watches we
watch Survivor together really Amazing
Race she looks amazing rage we've seen
every Project Runway oh yeah who you
rooting for this season well they okay
I'm gonna talk you about drag race
but I love reality television okay so
run away I will say this season I said
every season this season for some reason
we're not on board coz they switched it
up
it's Carly classes hosting it now trust
me it feels a little like it feels off
not off game but off my friend Fran was
cold but she'd definitely bring
something to the show her accent I miss
I miss you saying I miss it
I know I miss I like Christian Siriano a
lot I love him a lot because he tells it
like it is he can relate when he told
that what I've been watching this season
when he told the one guy that just got
voted off and spoiler alert that he was
like you're eating right now I didn't
eat for three days when I made a
collection he was like I can tell and
then that guy hooted off of that episode
yeah I was like oh I hope you notice
they're cutting it differently yes
there's like a certain it's almost like
they're trying to go more behind the
scenes and it looks a little edgier and
grittier yeah I like the I like the
Polish it's like the old cut
well--there's oh it's always been weird
to me because I think this is the
different thing between drag race and
Project Runway for me that I wish was
switched or Schwab's that they show that
they all live in a loft together yeah so
it's like okay do they did they say to
you tomorrow for poor me do they expect
the drama like real world style to
happen at the loft which doesn't really
because they're all professional adults
yeah but then drag race is what I wish
they put them all up in a house and they
kept cameras rolling on them so you like
the kind of behind-the-scenes drama
I love untucked on drag race I've
recently gotten into untucked which if
you're not watching tuck you're only
watching half the story
is so true girl when I was doing I like
when Clea and I guest judge they took us
behind the mirror so we could watch yeah
so we can watch them putting on the
makeup okay really they know obviously I
guess but they don't know exactly when
someone's actually standing right
because for people that don't know the
mirror that they're doing their makeup
on is a two-way mirror
to a mirror and a lot of like producers
and I think they get or like their
storylines because they must be able to
overhear everything candidly back there
and I was I was I was Stan I think I was
saying with Clea or somebody we were
behind the mirror and one of us was like
oh I think a drag queen caught me I
think today I like look directly like my
wife is a makeup artist and I the way
they I mean silky ganache that's like
nails on a chalkboard but it is so I
don't use it sorry but it's so dark
around her neck yeah but like contouring
and all that kind of stuff is
fascinating yeah and I still don't
understand how incredibly dark makeup on
the sides and the top mm-hmm it conjures
the face but then it's gone
like it's that whole it looks how you
bake it and stuff like that yeah I feel
like they always catch them in the
moments where they look like Marge
Simpson with like a makeup the make
shotgun of makeup where it just looks
like insane and then suddenly they're on
the runway and they look like pieces of
art like it's incredible a blending is
real but they they you're right though
cuz they do take them from some kind of
crazy face with it and then and then
they don't show that transition into
that like amazing transformation it's
it's pretty nice and were you had you
watched the show before going okay yeah
so we we had some friends of mine my
buddy John and his husband Jason I grew
up with John and so every week for
probably the past 10 years they would
always come over once a week and watch
we'd watch some reality show yeah and
then it went from I was before but then
it went to RuPaul's Drag Race and then
Klee and her wife Mia came over to watch
it and then it just became the tradition
and then one time we were like well
let's see it hope there's an ant
crawling on the
and then we just i think somebody
mentioned like mentioned the idea of us
you know guest judging and we were like
yeah mm-hm
and so it was quite a thrill oh my god I
mean it was I would be really fun yeah
it's a whole day that you're there for
us it was two days snatch game you did
snatch game which is the most iconic
episode of every season so did you know
going into it that you guys were judging
snatch game yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's
it's it's it's fine but it's also I
don't know if it's because I'm just such
a I don't know if I'm way too much of a
sensitive person or an empath or
whatever about I'm nervous for them and
when they are uncomfortable when it's
not necessarily their Forte or whatever
yeah oh it's just you I just I stopped
breathing
it was hard to kind of see that the ones
that were kind of struggling but the
next day the runway I mean that lip-sync
was oh you want to watch maybe the most
iconic lip-sync that's happened for
season it was kind of epic it was and it
was like watching Cirque de Soleil that
with that one I think it was Eevee yes
but the one that interviewed sugar cane
said that it was like watching Cirque de
Soleil and it really was yeah cuz Eevee
just did these back flips so insane and
I was jealous watching it on behalf of
you guys because I was like sometimes
you watch the lip syncs and they're a
little lackluster like they're fine yeah
but then when you get people that can do
acrobatics and like you're really
lip-synching for their life or their you
also feel like sometimes they do a lip
sync and the song choice you're like oh
it sucks for them it's probably hard to
dance yeah like a slow song or something
that you're like they can't do their
back flips to this then I will say last
season I forgot her name very tall and
skinny she had like a green dress on and
she did it to some kind of old I'm like
Judy Garland song and she turned it out
oh yeah yeah I'm forgetting to but I
don't remember some of them just make it
happen and I love reveals I love wigs on
wigs on wigs even had quite a reveal
that was incredible that was I was like
she is making sure she doesn't leave
that Celine Dion was a little yeah she
was fighting for her life
yeah but also I love every season
because in there like also sleight of
hand magicians in some way too that
they're one-upping each other in terms
of like what else they do reveal and how
they can reveal things yeah I went to a
couple seasons ago I got to go to the
live taping of the finale when Sasha
velour had the like petals I was out of
my brain and I screamed as if this is
like my brother that was like surviving
some like insane yeah and I forgot that
we're all on camera the whole time too
it was and we're sitting next to all the
other direct means that have been voted
off they're just Fanning themselves like
crazy in the audience I was just like
this is the fever dream that I want to
live for the rest of my life was also so
I remember that moment too and it was
came out of nowhere out of nowhere
there's rose petals under her wig and I
was like she held her posture as if yes
she she knew this whole time and she
also kind of reminds me of Eevee because
since they're not necessarily maybe
dancers or you don't really thought she
didn't have to lip-sync much and neither
did Eevee so you don't really know what
they're gonna bring the runway that's
why I like Eevee so much is because she
is such a wild card that you're like oh
you're gonna you're gonna do something
completely out of the box yeah
and she pulled out that hairspray she
had that wig on a wig wait when did you
guys were actually filmed in July last
year yeah July last year Wow yeah and it
was just what both of us were very
nervous cuz you know you and you're
going into I mean I don't know we were
just we were really nervous oh you want
to respect them because they're artists
and artists and it was we were excited
to be there because we were
and us but there's also something like
when they when they walk down the runway
everybody's got quick bits yeah they say
and you're just like I don't know if I
could be that quick and you see I don't
know you just it was all it makes like
you kind of had come I had compassion
for them too because they're in high
heels just standing there being judged
and as an actor you're you know and you
know what being judged let's see judge
them it was just kind of a weird and
then your job is to judge oh that's so
nuts and then you're also in the
presence of rue was just like enemy
immaculate like sentient being sent down
to like make us a better society yeah it
was really fun oh that's so nuts
well congratulation that the secret is
out now that you don't have to sit with
it are you rooting for anyone in
particular this season you think
anyone's gonna take the take the crown
I'm a Nina West fan alright yeah I think
Evy and Brooklyn I mean they're all
really great I just Nina is a seems like
a really kind person yes and just and I
appreciate that because I think it can
probably get pretty catty
yeah and just kind of gossipy and people
are just back and I just feel like Nina
kind of stays away from the drama and
it's just a kind person I'm like yeah
you that's what we need more and she's a
she's a wonderful goof like she has a
very old school like vaudevillian
quality to her and that I think is like
well she should have one sense you know
it's great
who did win snatched away with it yeah
well we'll see how it goes yeah what's
your other like reality show situation
other than survivor
are you into Bachelor are you into the
bachelors I just I just I I don't know
why I bachelor kind of makes me and I
don't know why they put themselves
through this I don't know why really
fair point do it I'm just like I don't
there's this is not
you know what how did I miss that
yeah I don't know it's just that kind of
makes me angry you into the competition
like amazing race survivors a
competition yeah and I'm trying and I
watch a lot of YouTube I watch a lot of
YouTube would you ever be on Amazing
Race no no no no I take it back I don't
know I maybe I might when my daughter
gets older would you do it with your
daughter that might be kind of a fun
might be kind of a fun thing because
she's such a fan here's the thing about
Amazing Race is I think I'd rather do
survivor because Amazing Race day God
nothing is more stressful than trying to
get to the airport and saying you know
I'm the guy that arrives at the gate
three hours or they just I'll have a
coffee because I don't want to be late
and it just it feels like one big
episode of being late yes
and I that just sounds that's just one
big nightmare to me yeah but so you'd
rather I haven't watched survivor for
years and years and years I'd forget
that it's still on just I've fallen out
of I mean I have to get a trainer I'd
have to really work on this it's like
super I mean I assume that it's evolved
and grown into this like not only just
like mental game but extremely physical
oh yeah and you always have your shirt
off which is like the whole time out of
the question fire that's another one
come on
where have we gotten I got into a weird
K home where I watch like 11 episodes of
naked and afraid in one day and I was
just like fascinated by it by like just
the actual like and then I watched all
the reunion episodes of them all coming
back together and like out machito each
other yes why their season because they
were in a swamp what's harder than the
desert that the other people were in and
I was like yes give me this like battle
of the brain I do have a question there
like what do you watch cuz I have to ask
myself this like what do you watch where
you walk away feeling good good
oh man falling off of boats um I've been
well that's interesting because I
watched The Bachelor because I'm
fascinated by like the human condition
of like why they put them all so it's
just like the intense like I watch
unreal for a while that scripted show
before I watched actually The Bachelor
and then watching how similar the two
was fascinating to me oh yeah unreal
like the narrative the storylines
narratives almost seem like they saw
into some like Oracle like crystal ball
of like the future seasons of The
Bachelor and they start like mirroring
each other in a very odd way but I think
it's just cuz you can kind of sort of
guess psychologically like where the
show is gonna do and like what's gonna
happen yeah it's just it's harder I
realized this season it was harder to
watch women compete for a man I think I
kind of had this like a tiny epiphany
for myself for some reason it was like
easier and funnier to watch like men
compete for a woman but I don't want
unreal they do both unreal
yeah they do both unreal yeah but the
actual bachelor watching like the actual
yeah I was like I don't know I don't
like this season I don't know maybe I'm
I guess I've become more of a feminist I
guess I just like think all these women
like should just live and thrive and not
have to do this but like watching the
men I'm like yeah yeah yeah exactly
keep them completely quarantined because
it cuz it does I asked that to myself
son because it's like when you see I
don't know like a magazine or something
like that and I have that gravitational
pull to kind of flip you know it just
because I'm bored or I'm interested or
it's gonna be like candy but then you
walk away and I'm like oh why did I do
that
I have an answer here's what I'd have
been binge watching because I've been a
little under the weather the last night
cause I'm sorry that's kind of going
around yeah I mean it's it's my fault
but a great British baking show that is
the one that you walk away from these
contestants won great at what they do to
support each other entirely there's not
a dramatic terrible person in the mix
No and all pastels it's all pastels it's
Easter every single episode and they all
genuinely want each other to do well
yeah and where they edit it that way
which I appreciate that it's so British
that literally because I watch a lot of
like Food Network reality there was an
episode I was watching their day where a
woman just is like I put my finger in
the fan okay it's bleeding and it was
like two seconds and the really whatever
the on-call person just came and wrapped
it up and then they kept going whereas
like if that was an episode of chopped
that would have been a dud and then I
cut away and insane music and they're
just so subtle and this grandmother kind
of figure comes around and talks about
your food the Hollywood guy is at least
he's probably the only one that adds an
edge of as close to Guy Fieri as they
get over but everybody else is very
genuine oh it's so pure like there's a
lot of authentic moment there's a lot of
real human like sweet you root for
everyone there's never really a
front-runner and there's never really a
villain and that's been the show that's
been giving me such wonderful feelings
every time I watch it
I will say like that's a good point
because on these other shows whether it
be The Bachelor so that when you do
because you're a very perceptive person
and when you do notice an authentic
moment you notice it oh yeah when you
know it's not coming out of like I want
more airtime where I'm gonna be just
getting into a fight or did it but when
you see an authentic moment that
wouldn't be a response or a question
you're like yeah that's authenticity
when you watch someone yeah that is
having a human moment that isn't aware
of cameras or thinking about like the
Edit of this episode down the line yes
because it's you know they're on the 20
billion season of it that you will now
go in already trying to preemptively
right there like story arcs for the show
which when you see the people that are
just genuine weirdos and assignment
weirdoes they're the most human ones of
all of them the weirdoes are the ones
that going and trying to write the
narratives yeah yeah but those people
are like I root for them I root for the
one that like really truly blissfully is
ignorant of all of this like nonsense
surrounding them so that's my Great
Britain would be really
cool too I don't think anybody would
have any produce would ever do this
because it would kind of show their
cards but if they could show an episode
how someone was edited to be the villain
and then how somebody else was at it
like to show you yeah
Oh a hundred percent if you could go
behind the scenes and show two versions
of an episode like here's a villain now
here's our hero it would be easy to do
so easy I feel like they probably have
all of those stocked episodes and they
just watch how it plays out I just like
release those but I've also watched a
lot of unreal and unreal is kind of
unreal so yeah okay we're gonna take a
quick break when we get back more
questions for Tony Hale we'll be right
back with more not your deep deep is
brought to you by aunt Fanny's which is
not only just a really cute brand to say
out loud audibly right now for myself
alone in my house but to very exciting
because for years we've been told that
clean meant one thing sanitize it's
supposed to be healthy but sanitizers
and just disinfectants wipe out
everything all the good healthy stuff
along with any bad like your gut your
home has a microbiome too and research
is starting to show that this kilomole
approach may be going too far with
negative effects on our health
especially for kids but now aunt Fanny's
brings probiotics to your home and your
hands with their new micro cosmic line
these household cleaners and hand soaps
add good with probiotic power each has
an extract of beneficial bacteria plus
super effective plant-based ingredients
to be tough on dirt and gentle on you
these formulas are non-toxic
cruelty-free and have 100% essential oil
sense
no fake fragrances here they're
hypoallergenic and dermatologist tested
too so you have all of the accolades
that you could possibly need for this
company why stop at just natural
cleaning when you can do one better with
probiotics shop now at aunt Fanny's calm
/ good and get 20% off your entire order
with the
Phung code grace at checkout that's aunt
Fanny's a untf and an IE s.com slash
good coupon code grace okay you have a
million things going on but also
everything is coming to an end and also
we're all gonna die and we're all gonna
die which is like the bigger take away
for everything okay toy story for ya
this is nuts congratulations this is
very exciting
it's so cool I'm like having a child
like this must be like an extra layer of
cool and yeah waves to like when they
first were kind enough to ask me I was
like oh what's that it's it's it's uh
you don't you know process I didn't
really process and I'm sure a gag I'm so
happy that's so nice and then you go and
then they I recorded at Pixar and I'm
like oh I'm at then I kind of looked
around it's like oh this is happening in
this place is like a creative Wonderland
yeah I know and then you see the trailer
and then you oh I because I think
there's that actor mentality of like
you're gonna get I'm gonna get cut that
reminds me of my wife when she worked on
SNL she said every single person that
came in to SNL always had the imposter
that somebody is going into but it was
like so then it kind of came to ways and
then this last time we were doing press
I guess a couple weeks ago and then it
hit me that it was like wow I'm I'm in
it so it kind of comes in waves it's
very exciting and you you've seen the
whole film I've seen it yeah I saw a
screening of it and it's just a it's
it's eye candy
you know like what Pixar does you're
just looking at these the way Bo Peep is
lit and it looks like China and it's
just I don't know it's like having you I
don't know how they do it yeah I'm just
like how do people know how to do this
yeah and then just the emotional roller
coaster that Sartre takes you on is
really great but it's wonderful because
it's I imagine it's you know for adults
and children at the same time there's so
much depth and there's so much like
emotional complexity to it that you're
like this just nuts but it's technically
for children and the basic truth my
character you know he's a sport who's in
the middle of an existential crisis
characters with nervousness and anxiety
and it must be kind of a oddly
complementary that you're like of course
I'm the person you reach out to so you
know just the fact that he has a lot of
questions because not only does he have
these real simple questions that he asks
about life like he'll walk in love at
toys drop to the ground he's like why
why is that my job
what is this the rules of the universe
and but also he's simple like he's a
spork and some pipe cleaners and little
piece of clay it's just it's a really
and also I mean the deeper thing is he
always wants to go to the trash he's
like I'm made for the trash and woody is
you know he's brought to give him a
greater purpose yeah Wow Wow
okay so he lots of Tears this when did
you get to see the actual character the
character like I think the firt the
first time they brought me in and you
never know what is right it's I tell you
though I don't know if you're like this
I even while I was even while I was
doing the voice for the first time I
genuinely wouldn't have been surprised
as somebody stood up and went yeah this
isn't working
I trust no I trust nothing
nothing I don't trust anything thank you
for the free lunch
I wouldn't even been ups have it up and
upset but I've been like it would have
been the response like oh yeah yeah I
know you're gonna say look I get it
I get I'm out that's so nice
and now okay what for the one question I
have because I think people might assume
that like voice-over acting is so much
easier than regular acting but like
maintaining your voice and actually
maintain the character's voice and like
having to emot-- just through your voice
seems like it's way more complicated
than people think
yeah I think yeah I mean to be
completely honest I've always had when I
was younger I had a lot of in into
college I had a lot of insecurities
about my voice really yeah so I always I
don't I just have this always insecure
to my voice I and I still probably do I
think I sound like I had a cold all the
time it's just something I had a real I
would hear myself and be like God I mean
I hear somebody who has like a deep
resonance and be like I sound like a
squeaky dog toy so it's like when
somebody says all they're gonna get is
what you're giving into the microphone
is and you you know you do podcast like
that's what so I think that I brought an
anxiety into that of like oh god like
because I used my facial expressions
physicality was a large part of kind of
communicating humor and the story yeah
and so it took some time to gain a
confidence and what I was putting into
the microphone and but like when you do
voice-over commercials I mean on
commercials animation mm-hmm
they'll always do a playback of how your
voice sounds and the characters just to
kind of keep that in your ear I'm not
just now I'm mysteriously doing some
other version I think that's Pixar
that's so cool is um typically when I've
done animation there's always a glass
much like it's like yeah it's like a
two-way mirror like RuPaul's Drag Race
except that's just
and you kind of you're doing something
and then everything turns off on your
headphones and you just see these people
talking about it they're talking yeah
and you can see the dresser at a pretty
straight going like all you see is their
emotions of like and all I'm hearing in
my head is like yeah they suck you know
it's like they're just talking so like I
think it and they're not probably not
saying anything bad but you don't know
right
Pixar you were all in the same room so
it was like I was in the same room with
them and that it almost helped the and I
just kind of felt a little more a part
of them yeah I mean someone that might
handle anxiety
I think the worst case scenario is
watching two people in charge silently
talk about something that you just did
as a performance by the way yeah just
watching that yeah you're doing on
camera like when I do leave the monitors
and kind of directors of they're in
another room typically so you don't see
them talking about right but I suffer
there is a piece of glass and you're
watching somebody judge you too emotive
mimes and you're trying to feel I'm sure
worst case scenario brain takes over but
the more you do it the more its you get
I get a lot more free with it like it's
just the more you can kind of bring your
own physicality into it as though you
were doing it on camera and I think it
transfers maybe into the performance a
little more on the microphone that's
cool that's very cool
I just read this morning you're you did
this interview for GQ that I thought was
really cool and like just talking about
anxiety and like dealing with that and
how cuz I also it handled that sure and
I think that's becoming a more
normalized conversation which I really
appreciate and really loved very much
yeah and you were talking about how you
said something about how like it's not
make it about you or like it's not like
I'm yourself or something yeah I think I
was giving the example I was doing Conan
years ago and I used to struggle with
panic attacks mm-hmm and I was doing
Conan this must have been probably seven
or eight years ago and they when they
introduced you they opened the curtain
and then you walk out and right I was I
was stating the curtain ready to go and
right before I could feel the way
of panic yeah for me when that happens
you all you want to do is bolt yep
that's all you want to do and through
you know a [ __ ] like just kind of
learning techniques and one of the
techniques is to somehow get your eyes
off yourself and so there was two guys
standing next to the curtain that were
about to open it and I just started
asking them questions so I was like oh
are you from oh and I remember actually
specifically saying wouldn't it be fun
if a documentary was made about what you
guys see right before somebody goes out
or great idea you know in like what how
long he'd be doing this job just to
force my eyes off myself and and then
the curtains open and then I went out
you know so it's because if I had stayed
in my head it just gets it snowball
snowball see ya know I thought that was
such a really like simple and seems like
common sense but when you're in your
anxiety brain with panic attack is about
to like the wave comes over you sure
it's impossible to like think that
clearly about things and the impulse and
everybody probably already knows this
but the impulse is to fight yeah the
anxiety and to fight the panic mm-hmm
and you have to just let it wash over
you yeah and it's that's the most
unintentional it's the way to say it
that's not the default right just to run
and one other technique that I learned
just a lot about is kind of touching
things around you so it's like oh yeah
touching this table touching my jacket
because with anxiety I'm somewhere else
yeah I'm just I'm in a fantasy that
hasn't happened yet I've heard the the
sense mechanism thing where it's like
what do I smell right now and then you
identify what you smell what am i
tasting in my mouth right now what do I
hear right now what do I feel right now
that's good and that gets you out of
your head a little bit and just more in
the present sense I'm like where you are
oh I like that yeah and it seems like it
should be common sense but again like
it's you unless you actually start
practicing it and like build that muscle
memory but that's yeah once I heard that
I was like that's genius
and nothing is rational in those mom no
it's almost I compare it to when
somebody there's a person in my life and
the histor that he they keep making
these choices that I don't understand it
makes me very very crazy and I really my
wife and I talked about the words we're
trying to make something irrational
you know and I'm trying to be like what
and I'm fighting this and it's like this
is never going to be rash this is you
rational behavior I'm trying to make it
rational and that's why I'm driving
myself crazy so in this kind of anxiety
I can spend so much time trying to
figure out and why is this happening and
fighting and it's like it's just it's
just thoughts and feelings that come and
go that really mean nothing most of the
time yeah you know and it's really just
hurting myself to spend that much time
trying to figure it out yeah no that's
absolutely true and I yeah when you
don't the brain is like wonderful and
terrible all at the same time yeah yeah
beacon of beautiful stuff and also like
your worst enemy and the stronger it
gets the crazy yeah I think just having
like smaller coping mechanisms and just
like very kind of simple understandings
of and everything's easier said than
done
obviously and pour in the moment it's so
it that's why I keep saying I think it's
a it's a discipline it's not something
that happens overnight somebody else
said something be to that I love like
you know we're just the worst to
ourselves and we're the worst and if my
daughter ever came out to me and said
dad you know I feel like [ __ ]
I can't believe I'm doing this I'm awful
I would be like honey you're the most
amazing I love you and yet we don't talk
to ourselves that way yeah I guess and
you we have I have to I want to talk to
myself like I went my daughter when
she's going through so that's so smart
I think there's a weird sense of like
narcissism by being nice to yourself and
like kind of yeah there's a real bad
about yeah they're like I'm an egomaniac
because I think that I should love
myself like that's no you should that's
okay yeah there's nothing selfish or
weird or like you know egomaniacal about
that and it's even blake in faith they
say love others as you love yourself
there's a lot of value actually it's
difficult to paulie's right I mean
there's a principle it is cuz there
really is a power and it comes from you
when you have to
foundation there's a yeah greater love
for others yeah no that's super cool um
I'll bring him back the rube bring it
back mama mama Roos she's with us
constantly every day all day
okay let's talk about Archibald's next
big thing oh yeah yeah so this is the
amount of things baby yeah I was gonna
say I read a little bit about it and it
sounded like he kind of grew out of this
sort of thought process and this was a
children's book that you wrote years ago
that has now become an animated series
ah yeah it's um so when I was living in
New York I apologized to people who have
heard this but it's become I get a
little bit of soapbox because it's it
was very impactful for me but when I was
in New York I was finding myself not
very present and not that I had a bad
time in New York but not very present
but always look into that big thing
coming like that my big thing is coming
so whenever something happened that was
hard and that I was like you know what
that big thing is coming something's
coming and when I booked my in a sitcom
was my big thing and when I booked that
sit come on Arrested Development it
didn't satisfy me the way I thought I
was gonna satisfy and it really scared
me because that was my dream
yeah and it's because I gave it too much
weight and it's the whole thing if
you're not practicing contentment where
you are you're not gonna be content when
you get what you want oh and I think my
whole time in New York I again I didn't
have a bad time but I was just never
where I was yeah there's always
somewhere else in the future and I think
that I had to and I do that's why I keep
on saying discipline because it's
something that I had to learn so anyways
in the children's book Archibald is a
chicken and he gets a card in the mail
that says your big thing is here and
he's like where and he goes on all these
great adventures but every time he's on
an adventure he's like I got to get to
my next big thing and I love that you
have bees today because there's a bee in
the book that always says damn you got
to just be man you gotta just be and
then in the end he realized that the
card is right that your big thing is
right here my big thing in my life is
talking to you right now that's my big
thing and more that we can treat
everything like a big thing it's like
everything then just unfolds you don't
give it so much expectation and wait
mm-hmm and so in the cartoon I arch Mull
to pretty much my my role model like I
would love to be Archibald but he just
walks into a situation he sees the best
in people he sees the best in the
situation
he's learned the power of the now almost
yeah yeah yeah he's funny and just I
don't know he's it's taught me a lot he
continues to teach me a lot of lessons
that's super cool and I think that's
huge
I struggle with that a lot okay we all
do I still show you like what's the next
thing that's happening today if I'm
nervous about this thing especially
auditioning in that whole thing I'm
never present because I'm just like I
get to go do this after this so I don't
worry about this right now sure but
we're also keeping in mind we're also
trained to not think of them now like
especially as freelancers we get the
question what's next for you yeah my
default is to think somewhere else my
default isn't to be present it's more of
a challenge for me to be right here and
and also keep in mind it's not like I'm
saying because people have asked it like
do you think dreaming is wrong or do you
think you know ambition and I'm not
saying that but I think for me I was I
was kind of subconsciously saying I will
have value when this happens right I
will have value when a sitcom happens
and something it could be something else
for somebody else I when I have children
I love it's like whatever that is rather
than and also in our town in Hollywood
it says you will have value when this
happens and let me tell you right now my
value back in the mid 90s when I was
temping I was trying to make a sign my
value is the exact same then as it is
right now my value has not changed when
are you writing a self-help book by the
way I suck at this so much that's why I
like to talk about it because I struggle
anxiety has been and this is another
cool thing is like um I think our
society
it's even though [ __ ] is hard anxiety is
hard when people go through [ __ ] it's
very very hard but it's amazing how it's
the stuff that teaches us the most it's
the stuff that changes us the most and
not that not I mean there's so much joy
from mountaintop experiences but man
[ __ ] grows in the valley yeah that's
where the stuff grows there's a lot of
snow on the Mount that they're joyful
guys but I look at my life and it's the
[ __ ] that really brings out you know
another thing that kid I'm getting all
spiritual but get it God talks about
like he will restore what the locusts
have eaten there's
kind of a story in the Bible that says
that and it's a beautiful thing of like
I think God and I faith is important to
me and it's it's God really does take
what the locusts have eaten or take what
the world says and he will I believe he
will restore it in different unique ways
and and my I mean look at my characters
yeah all strike it's something that I
have been able to use yeah in my life
somehow and I think that you create
closer connections that way because
these are authentic personalities or
characters to things that you struggle
with so then the people that identify
with this or that find meaning or
relatability and all these narratives
have a and like there's visibility there
I've like an understanding and it
becomes like okay this is kind of normal
and okay like I'm not weird I'm not
crazy I'm not you know completely alone
right now we're spending on a planet
it's like if you it is it's okay it
makes sense that we have yeah anxious
times and you know one thing that for me
with anxiety that I that really taught
me with the characters is like for
instance Gary on veep he's very tough is
very internal like he kind of will stand
behind her and there's a lot going on
that you had and anxiety is not so much
in people's face all the time it's like
hey hey I'm freaking out it's very much
of a silent war yes yeah you know and
it's hard to verbalize sometimes it's
hard to articulate sometimes and so then
it becomes unbelievable to people from
the outside to imagine that someone
could struggle with someplace because
it's not it's you know it's not like
measles that show up on your body so
you're obviously sick or you're
struggling with something it's very very
internal very internal but it doesn't
make it any less real not at all no I
think that's really cool and I think the
idea of creating like it is the is the
animated series like for children it's
like six yeah it's like six to ten and
he is he has and his sister's name is
Loy on the show that's so sweet
and he has a sister and two brothers and
it was created from the book my buddies
Victor Huckabee and Tony be Agni did it
with me and then this series of my
friends Jake drew and Eric and in the
series he just I don't know he's a
little he makes a lot of mistakes makes
a lot of mistakes but his attitude
towards the mistakes is what it's about
you know he just and there's always some
kind of global reason for these mistakes
that happen cuz you know mistakes get a
bad rap like a lot of mistakes but
there's always something many times a
kind of a hidden a lesson a lesson from
him yeah there's an education and
mistakes lesson if you I don't I mean
can you imagine meeting someone that had
never made a mistake they would be the
worst person niece's wedding and we had
a great time and you know there was a
lot of them getting ready for a wedding
there was a lot of anxiety or right you
could just feel like you know wants it
to be really fun but I remember thinking
on my wedding it really wasn't the
perfection that I remember it's always
the mistakes it's I remember when
anyways there was a situation where like
I would I would call now there was a we
really odd speech we always talked about
and now it brings us a lot of joy but at
the time it's like at the time like
what's like traumatized prioritizing but
it but that's what's always talked about
yeah like how beautiful the weather was
man you have a whole series of life help
a lot of pain oh I love it okay speaking
of pain we're gonna take a quick break
and then we get back we have Twitter
questions for you Twitter one of the
social media platforms of pain
out there back with why not to do this
episode of not too deep is brought to
you by better help if there is something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
better help online counseling can help
better help offers licensed professional
counselors who are specialized in issues
such as depression anxiety of
relationships trauma anger family
conflicts etc etc connect with your
professional counselor and a safe and
private online environment and get help
at your own time and at your own pace
anything you share is confidential and
it's so convenient you can schedule
secure video or phone sessions as well
as chat and text with your therapist if
for some reason you are not happy with
your counselor though you can request a
new one at any time for no additional
charge and best of all it's a truly
affordable option not too deep with
grace helbig listeners get a 10% off
your first month with the discount code
so if you're interested get started
today go to better help calm such grace
then simply fill out a questionnaire to
help them assess your needs and get you
matched with a counselor that you will
hopefully love that's better help calm
slash grace okay here we go we're
getting real deep I'm not too deep when
it comes to vibrators there is no
one-size-fits-all everyone has a
different body but that's why skin s Kyn
condoms have a new line of intimate
devices these vibrators are oh mazing
you heard me right yeah that's the ad
copy and I'm reading it as is and I'm
gay I hope my parents don't listen to
this episode but that said I'm very very
excited that we're supported by this
brand listen up there's the thrill which
is a more discreet bullet equipped with
three different speeds then there's the
shiver which is a waterproof massager
with seven different speeds the shiver
also has a ribbed texture for multiple
sensations ladies get at it and if
you're a dude buy one for your girl or
yourself I don't know it's for an
chance meant not replacement every
bedroom should have at least one sex toy
again I'm reading an ad copy
mom dad stepmom stepfather so save
intimacy and feel everything with skin
you can order skin devices right from
Amazon just search skin that's SK why
and to explore the entire line of
intimate products well how I wish that
they had a I don't get it a code grace
on this one all right back to the
podcast okay before we get into these
Twitter questions I'm gonna ask you the
two questions asked every single guest
that is on the podcast I'm sorry
they're very thrilling the first one is
who alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at okay okay can
you give me a second to think of course
of course like Barbara Walters would say
I I've been incredibly honored I work
with I don't work with them when they go
on missions but I go to anyways I'm
involved in the international justice
mission that works with human
trafficking uh-huh and hearing these
stories about these adults and how
they're abusing children is I would like
to throw a lot more than cold yeah yeah
maybe like completely still like maybe
actual like its life sentences that I
and then there's and this sounds very
general but just mean people mm-hmm I
don't under I mean there's a it's just
it doesn't produce any good fruit
there's no reason to do it yeah it takes
more energy to be like purposely mean
than to just exist in like just be nice
if you're the girl should just be nice
dude be nice have you heard of it no
it's a great organization that's they
just a very simple model just dude be
nice just be nice that's great yeah
that's okay okay the other question is
to tell us your worst pants [ __ ]
story or a close call but I
have one Oh perfect but here's the deal
you can only tell us in three words or
three small phrases so mine is college
jogging front lawn okay I love that you
have one so immediately that makes me so
full of joy
so phrases meaning you can do like
little phrases or I mean there's really
no rules people have gone full out and
told us their whole story I was okay
okay one phrase would be I'll just do
one sentence on the subway to rehearse
with my scene partner sentence okay I
arriving okay thought a fart
I missed mistook a fart arrived at her
apartment and and randomly asked if her
husband and he's sweatpants I could
borrow and never told her why I think
actually her however I did not tell her
at the time I might have told don't
think I ever did tell her but I remember
I leaving the we were Hurst in my
husband's sweatpants and then we left
and I throw away those pants in the
trash outside and then I ran and her and
her husband got divorced years later and
I ran into her husband who's an actor at
a party in LA and told him the whole
story
oh my god cuz he wasn't in the apartment
when it happened I told her I said if
you were missing a pair of sweat pants
this is why just know your ex-wife
didn't vindictively burn them feeling of
Oh especially in New York
oh man that's like what am I gonna do I
know now in New York that there's gotta
be apps for public bathrooms but I
remember always having at the time that
I live there a mental map of like I can
go to Italy
I think W Hotel in Union Square Marriott
in Times Square is [ __ ] rock-solid
they have so many choices and no one
uses them because it's a hotel and
everyone's up in their own room
any chain hotel and you're walking with
confidence no one stopped solid okay
let's get into these Twitter questions
okay
a lot of people ask the same type of
question beeping Arrested Development or
my favorite shows can you ask him about
the differences on each set differences
on each set I would say the process is
really different because unarrested
it was like its own puzzle where Mitch
would like I remember when my hand when
my hand was eaten off by a seal and I
remember episodes before seeing like a
hand chair and like I think about a hand
I was like what's up with all the hand
stuff like I don't even what this means
like why do I want to talk about hand
stuff and then cut to literally my hands
eaten off and if I had messed up that
grid right you just all kind of trusted
that just say what's on the page yeah
whereas on veep the writers worked very
hard but then they give us rehearsal
time just to kind of see if stuff is
gelling and come up with bits and all
that kind of stuff
oh that's cool yeah so you guys kind of
it's a collaborative sort of it felt
veep it's there they're both
collaborative but veep definitely I
never had this much rehearsal time on a
television show as I do on V yeah how is
that is that do you like that more
aye-aye
I do I like it feels kind of like
theater where you feel a little more
confident walking into a day of shooting
okay yeah that makes sense then you feel
like more you fully understand
everything and it's also a real
organized chaos on veep yeah and so to
know exactly where the choreography have
people kind of coming and going house
that's cool
someone's know how awkward was working
with the hook slash fake hand and
Arrested Development mm-hmm awkward
slash awesome
and that made me cackle out loud I loved
it it was fun it was fun because it's
you know especially these last two
seasons they would just come up to me
and we didn't I didn't know one none of
us really knew it was happening in the
story and so he was just someone just
come to me and say this is the hand
you're wearing you know can you explain
why and I remember specifically one
props person just going I don't know
it's one big trust exercise that's so
great
I'm someone know do you think the role
of Buster Bluth positively affected your
life it'd be weird of you saying
absolutely not
oh yeah it definitely I mean the the job
in the plant having that role definitely
yeah pause be upon playing him yeah
because I think there is I kind of what
I was talking about before it kind of
began to open the door of seeing how you
know stuff that was really hard with
anxiety to walk through how it could you
know be used in comedy and to your point
of finding those authentic places ya
know do you what's been the most I don't
want to say weird or negative but like
strange fan interaction or like someone
coming up and and talking to you I
actually I actually enjoy people come up
because I don't remember the episodes I
haven't seen many of them so I mean I've
seen them in the air but that's about it
and so when people come up be like hey
remember when this happened and I'm like
I don't but it sounds really it sounds
really funny so I enjoy when they tell
me but I remember a couple of people
will if I conversation with somebody
they'll stand really close to me and I
don't know if they're trying to think if
I sound like buster bluth or kind of
linger
linger and they'll just like they'll
just say oh they'll go hey brother hey
brother and then I'll go hey so nice
nice to meet you but I don't I don't
know how what else to say
have you ever been mistaken for a
celebrity yeah well I I don't know if
I've been mistaken uh maybe I I know I
know when I was doing commercials
I was the David Schwimmer type and I was
described as checked out and not all
there
[Laughter]
oh yeah someone's asking who are you
rooting for in this season of drag race
and what was it like being a guest judge
Oh who's your preferred boy band Oh
if you have one prefer boy band hmm what
kind of music do you listen to I listen
to you know Patty Griffin is I do not
she's music I know I love Spotify
because you just kind of listen to a
variety stuff that you don't know about
I was heard a lot of her I listened to I
listen to these band called actually the
the the this being called distant
cousins which I really have anyways
they're kind of this alternative yet but
a boy band I mean I don't know NSYNC
immediately comes to my mind yeah didn't
they do rock your body rock your button
they all perfect right so Backstreet
Boys in Vegas a couple months ago and it
delivered they were fantastic I have no
idea I'm not clearly making Bank
oh they're and they're all family men
residency that they have it yes it is I
slid into the DMS of the Backstreet Boys
on Twitter and not my finest proudest
moment but it was yes
it was and it's everyone's screaming
their brains out and it was just like
the most fun ever and they're I mean
they can dance on a show and they're
like dads and husbands I'm so impressed
and I forgot how many hit songs they
have I mean keep its back straight and
sync and what are the other 190 degrees
was out there at one point yeah O'Town
sure they had a reality show didn't they
did they yeah yeah they had O'Town hits
on top of town is infamous for liquid
dreams this song about coming in here
sleep yeah and they name a lot of a-list
celebrities it was I remember when I
heard it first I was in high school I
was like oh this is catchy and then like
in college mean like what the [ __ ]
that's nuts we are all pranked okay
someone to know what kind of
entertainment do you like to relax to
YouTube yeah what do you watch on
YouTube I just watch compilation videos
I really do I like a lot of the like any
kind of the America's Got Talent but
only the ones that win you watch like
the dance i watch a lot of So You Think
You Can Dance So You Think You Can Dance
kind of stuff like big dance troop stuff
to pump myself up cuz I can't do that
likes fully out of my wheelhouse yeah
yeah yeah and then I watch a lot of that
kind of stuff I recently got into
gender-reveal cuz it's like I don't I
like that I think it's that element of
joy and surprise of the children that
hate they're like next brother-sister
and the kids it's just such a joyful
time so it's fun to see kind of that
love compilations have to come wrack my
brain and figure out a couple ray Ellen
sends people through the haunted house
oh and she sends Andy her especially
today but the writer girl oh yes yes she
got her Scream was perfect there's an
actually speaking of screams side note
is this um have you guys seen that
Netflix characters where actors play
different characters I've heard of it I
hadn't seen it there's one episode where
John early it's not his show but it's
this other girls and he's playing kind
of her assistant of this art dirt
anyways he comes in and gives out this
scream that is the most genuine startled
scream I've ever heard and I must I
think I rewound it like five thousand
times it's so funny you know what I'm
talking about
no you're giving out recommendations
some let's go what was you're supposed
to know when was your last fit of
existential dread I would say
existential I mean I think every day I
don't know but I don't know about dread
but I'm definitely like i'll be i'll be
i'll be walking i'll be somewhere and
just want to be like hey you know what
we're gonna die i mean this is this is
all fleeting actually this makes me
think of something i'm i remember I was
working years ago and not that I haven't
had my moments and I'm that I'm not
proud of but I remember working with
this producer who was just a douchebag
okay just a douchebag and I wanted so
bad and I did it and I'm glad I held my
tongue but I wanted so bad to be like
you know what I was recently at a
graveyard and we're all going there and
your legacy is that you're a dick is
that you're a douchebag yeah and if you
want that to be your legacy
great yeah keep going the way you're
going but you have the ability to make
different choices you have the ability
to treat people better or people are
just gonna remember you as a douchebag
and that's a bummer
yeah but you didn't say that and I
didn't say it cuz that's a very polite
way to say [ __ ] you directly cuz I mean
I don't know if it would do anything but
it goes back to that like you have your
legacy can be there's all the stealthy
all the stuff we'd sleeting yeah but how
you treat people your relationships
that's the [ __ ] that really has
longevity oh that is very impactful I'm
very meaningful to me i resonate with
that a lot and think more and more as I
get older and closer to that graveyard
like yet none of this [ __ ] matters
we're all gonna die someday
that's like the fun joke we've had on
set with my friends and I that anytime
someone's really nervous about a scene
you just tap each other on the shoulder
and whisper we're all gonna die someday
and then it really puts things in
perspective
there's actually something kind of
comforting because it makes it to me it
really makes me value those moments yeah
make them the kindest and most loving
that you can uh you're gonna be a great
dad someday my daughter's like someday
Toni we've reached the end of the
podcast thank you so much so fun but
before you go everyone that's a guest
gets a personalized fortune cookie to
you yeah now it's stuck in there so I'm
just oh I love this stuff okay ready
uh-huh
oh this is fun okay not to alarm you but
frozen to is coming out of November and
you quote will be forced to watch please
prep coping mechanisms with a therapist
now yeah because you hate frozen Oh are
these personalized yeah well here's the
thing about frozen yeah I do like frozen
it's some dark material it is the girl
has has a disorder where she touches
things frozen and she's in isolation for
your sister and they grow up in
isolation and all the other sister wants
to is like will you play us don't build
a snowman with man and it's you watching
you're like well the poor they've never
communicated and by the way side note so
parents died in the boat crash in the
very beginning what okay see I only
watch the second half of the movie so
there's a lot that I'm missing out on
but yeah that's dark a [ __ ] man
personally where do you get personalized
fortune cookies um you can buy a box and
just shove in a piece of computer
yeah thank you can get empty fortune
cookies oh yeah a game of operation on
it well done okay so for people that
don't know where can they find you and
what you're up to over the next few
months online or nice like mr. Tony Hale
is my handle yeah I like that because I
almost when I asked for Twitter
questions tweeted got the wrong and then
I'm excited guys beep is wrapping up
which is kind of sad
and then Toy Story is coming and
Archibald's next big thing in toy stores
coming on June and the Archibald's next
big thing is going to come out in the
fall that's awesome thank you again so
much for making time it's really really
love you're wearing mr. Rogers
neighborhood I'm setting the tone gonna
be a happy place yeah thank you guys for
listening we'll see you guys next time
another not too deep goodbye 2deep 2deep
2deep 2deep 2deep has been brought to
you by aunt Fanny's you heard me
correctly for years we've known about
probiotics for our guts but yet our
cleaning supplies are busy wiping out
all the good with the bad so bring a
probiotic power to your home with the
new microcosmic cleaners and hand soaps
from aunt Fanny's they add good with a
beneficial bacteria extract plus safe
plant-based cleaners
they're tough on dirt and gentle on you
so shop aunt Fanny's calm such good and
use the coupon code grace a check out
for 20% off your entire order not too
deep as a production of grace Helbig
incorporated producer and edited by
Melissa Dumont's writing by Diane Kang a
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]